and did they approach you too or did you
approach them who initiated the curse
being approached yeah although all of
our partners we approached you know and
pretty much most of the partnerships
were sort of like in-kind sponsorships
you know we didn't get any like cash
sponsorships but but you know IKEA was
another one and then
Dickenson marine and soul solutions and
yeah yeah so if you're a filmmaker in
your project lends itself to those kinds
of things it's not a bad route to go you
know we've we've had a lot of success
with it and yeah yeah I think yeah as
long as we're pretty careful to sort of
let people know from the beginning that
this is a documentary you know it's not
like a product placement it's not like
you know but sort of we were able to
sort of make separate videos for the
companies that were sort of like you can
use this video for promotional material
that's not necessarily us endorsing you
in our film you know because this is a
documentary but sort of thinking about
other ways that we could leverage the
material that we had that wouldn't
necessarily compromise the integrity of
you know the documentary film right
which it actually can be a real benefit
to you know our project as well from for
instance we're sharing content IKEA but
I akia's going to take that put it on
the blog probably so that'll also help
you know promote Harbor our films so
it's sort of this kind of it's a
partnership you know it's very
collaborative and so it's a really great
solution for some things what was your
first contact a phone call
it was email how long yeah it was for
like he has specifically you know I cook
old the I think it was like you know
product review kind of team in their
national marketing office and kind of
started with an email of like you know
we're doing this project you can you
know see the link here we're interested
in you know maybe using some of your
products and the house and sort of
seeing how it can tie in and it kind of
yeah sorted that way and I did a
follow-up phone call and you know there
were plenty of people that we reached
out to that we didn't you know hear
backs well I mean Home Depot and things
like that so yeah I mean it was kind of
just like a process of like we always
tried to email first and then call
because when you call you can always
refer back to the email rather than
having to like explain the whole project
in a monologue on the phone with this
person and like on the phone trying to
yeah
and having fennel neck and I think it's
important for people considering this
option to keep in mind that you really
need your film really needs to relate to
the company that you're approaching you
know for them to like really because the
way it doesn't necessarily make sense
for them as a company to support a film
about say I don't know landmines in you
know Southeast Asia when they're a home
decorating company and so I think just
being wise and strategic about who you
approach it saves everybody a lot of
time because honestly they're not gonna
get back to you you know if you you're
gonna take all this time preparing it
and so I think that we were really
careful about approaching companies that
really made sense for us to approach and
and actually the ones that made the most
sense were the ones that were interested
and the ones that were made less sense
were less interested so did you have a
rule in terms of if you did the email
and then you followed up with a call
then you would just drop it from there
or did you say I'm gonna keep trying a
few more times
yeah I mean I don't think I think the
people that we ended up working with we
heard back from I think you know within
one or two tries we're pretty lucky you
know I think that I probably I mean we
could have probably
and a little bit more aggressive in
terms of like really trying to reach
people but you know just in terms of we
had to decide what to focus our time and
energy on and I think you know we
decided to really kind of focus on the
film and the story rather than you know
focusing on pitching for funding but I
think we could have done more of that
you know but yeah well I mean with
documentaries like you mentioned earlier
you got I mean you really want to be
careful about the corporatization of of
it because it you know it kind of
controlled like your message one
reflects on the company that sponsors
you and to even you sort of become
beholdin in a way to whatever interest
they have and so you know I'm kind of
glad it didn't work out with say a
company like Home Depot because you know
maybe they would have been happy with us
this whole downsizing thing or perhaps
they would have had me on that I don't
know that but where perhaps they could
have pressured us to leave something out
or something not that that would have
happened and we probably wouldn't have
allowed that to happen but but that's
just something to keep in mind you know
and so I think that we didn't want to
like chase companies too much because
you know we were sort of a little bit
skeptical about doing it in the first
place thing is you have to sell the
project to the company you have to be
careful about like exactly what you're
selling to them whereas the companies
maybe ended up working with you know we
were lucky in that they were sort of
like yeah you know we don't they're
they're not expecting anything from us
other than to you know use the products
and then we're sort of doing these other
supplementary sort of blogs and things
that they can use outside of the actual
documentary
you